[Music]
so uh
nick what does ob gyn stand for
uh vagina doctor good that's all what's
the actual is it that's an acronym right
all i the gynecomastia i know college
colleges oh oh optional gynecology
that's what it is
it's elective you know
it's an elective
it's like peace christian and
gynecologist but what's the yn like
yeast infection i think that's the
gynecologist
gynecology why they do that's not an
acronym
it's like short form because
ob gyn ob is the the
give me that lady gotta play take a
oftentimes like old men see that
we always i always thought that and i
always thought that was wrong whatever
that is they got to cut that out yeah
they're hella horny you know okay like
can you imagine these [ __ ] going to
medical school and they're like man all
of these things [ __ ] whack brain
surgery is a [ __ ] yeah see i gotta
learn
like who's that guy because the amount
of work you have to do to be ob gyn is
probably immense like i gotta study
[ __ ] all day
everyone says you should follow your
passion i like [ __ ] i'm gonna follow it
and then they realize
all this other stuff like oh it's a
broken [ __ ] it's like smegma
it sounds like you're ob gyn now bro
like i don't want to do that one your
vagina doctor now
that's the medical term yeah i know
right doctor i broke my [ __ ] it's like
i don't want to see a lot of broken
[ __ ] such a weird prank
can somebody come here with the washed
car hello i love the [ __ ] moment
where you're choosing you're like brain
dog and that's [ __ ]
and the thought that like if you become
an ob gyn you always see the most
perfect
and it's gonna be like a sexy
funny that's such a funny well um this
this particular obgyn
uh plans to open
a floating abortion clinic to help those
in states with restricted access to care
like literally floating yeah
floating
castle yeah like a [ __ ] raft it's not
water water it's like a miyazaki movie
because of international water water
whoa that's for real yeah
you got a jet ski it's like not state
run waters like federal water so it's a
[ __ ] boat behind the floating [ __ ]
clinic
[Laughter]
broken [ __ ] clinic going on cruising
the smegma clinic so they're all like
[ __ ] carnival carnival presents
don't try to look into the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the boat's [ __ ] rocking like this
the whole time
and the girl
she's all like
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] it's planned parenthood on
the sea dude that's fire someone got to
do it that's a dope cruise someone gotta
do it there's plan b and plan c dude
it's plan c
thank you thank you as abortion rights
are being stripped in several states
throughout the u.s some ob gyns uh
abortion rights advocates and others are
focusing on how to make abortion
accessible and safe for those who live
in states where the procedure is
restricted or banned this is gonna
create a new market dude the situation
has led to some outside-the-box thinking
or outside of the land uh including most
recently plans by an obg01 to provide
abortions on a ship in federal waters
wow the brainchild of dr meg autry an
obgyn and professor or professor at the
university of california san francisco
who founded the non-profit project
prowess which stands for protecting
reproductive rights of women endangered
by state statutes damn oh prowess isn't
a nice acronym yeah way better than ob
gyn that's good that's really good
branding that's that's yeah i mean
that's how you do that industry can take
note
audrey is uh currently raising
the 20 million dollars needed to secure
a ship that would be retrofitted to
serve as a floating representative take
the queen mary they don't know what
they're going to do with that [ __ ] yeah
dude get rid of the [ __ ] queen mary
that's it
it's state-owned yeah it's doc i love
the queen mary dude
during halloween you go there for like
is it haunted is it really haunted
it's it's not the berry farm really
haunted though hey dude didn't people
die on queen mary yep is that a high
school dance there we had high school
dancers
we had our high school dance at the
[ __ ] california science museum
you get to take the picture with the
[ __ ] electrical in the hair no we
didn't even do that
yeah
you know
so yeah the uh the reproductive health
clinic uh is meant to have volunteer
providers offering low cost or free
surgical abortions up to 14 weeks along
with contraceptives testing and
treatment for sexually transmitted
infections and vaccines or vaccinations
that's really nice yeah that's honestly
pretty fun yeah
she austria has actually been an ob gyn
a productive a reproductive health
provider for 30 plus years and is an
army veteran
says she's no stranger to anti-abortion
sentiment and could see that the country
was heading towards roe v wade being
overturned
quote rights were being eroded
progressively over the years then the
dobs decision was leaked and it's like
this is happening even then there was a
silver a sliver of hope you just kept
thinking in your mind this can't be true
and when it hit it was devastating damn
yeah i just thought it was really cool
that people were trying to do this and
you know still figure out ways to
legally
support people that you know just need
the help are the people who like perform
abortions in hospitals are they ob gyns
is that what the
person is uh i don't know i don't know i
don't think all the time i feel like
obgyns are
um they specialize in that so abortion
clinics happen sometimes at like uh
other facilities and stuff right can
abortions happen uh at like regular
hospitals or anything i have no idea but
i do know that ob gyn specialize in the
female reproductive system so whatever
facility they're doing it at they
probably are under the supervision of
the ob gyn yeah they have to be you
think this uh cruz is gonna have free
pizza and
ice cream
yeah
dude that's so sick you get sucked out
of here you're just gonna eat pizza you
should have the amenities i think i
think it's kind of like when you go to a
dentist you know and then like when
you're a kid you're just like [ __ ] i
hate this [ __ ] and then they bust out
the basket full of toys and stuff and
then you can [ __ ] read a highlights
magazine the thing where the beat
follows the message yeah
so then i'm just kind of picturing it
like maybe it's like a cool cruise you
know like it's kind of sad you got to do
what you got to do but then afterwards
you get like free vanilla ice cream or
something man how many people are going
to afford
to even pay for that like
those states are poor
got doing like a duffy bill or something
thinking like a businessman i was just
thinking like maybe it's a non-profit or
something yeah i wonder what the price
breakdown is for that yeah
you mean in terms of the ship
well the experience the experience
because like i don't know how like you
got to get a [ __ ] dizzy pass like
fast pass to get there at the front of
the line yeah yeah
you know is it crazy to ask how much
abortions are is that a crazy well i
think they're offering services using
like funds and stuff like that for like
i thought planned parenthood does that
[ __ ] for free it was like it was like
300 something something like one well i
mean like if you can't afford it all
right so real quick just so that we
don't sound absolutely stupid let me
clarify some second semester abortions
run
an average of twelve hundred dollars
late term abortions can be even more at
three thousand damn
why is it so good
pappy was free dude no not plan b that's
the day after i'm talking about there's
an abortion pill when you're in your
first trimester oh yeah
dude when i was at when i was at cvs
there's a sign that says you can only
buy one plan b per day or something like
that because i think people are buying
them looking for more than that
people i think people were like buying
them in bulk yeah because of the road
yeah for sure which is kind of [ __ ]
crazy you know but
abortion bill is 289 dollars
whoa that's crazy and that's first
trimester so just be clear ob does stand
for obstetrics or obstetrician a
physician who cares for women and their
babies during pregnancy and childbirth
the gyn stands for gynecology or
gynecologist a physician a physician who
specializes in treating female
reproductive conditions i thought obj
one answered for official baby guy you
know official baby guy obgyn kenobi
wow um
he's just watching the show that's why
it's fresh on his mind
let's see uh when should a girl first
see a gynecologist age 13 to 15
uh blah blah blah how much does the ob
gyn make that's fun 208 000 have you
guys seen a dick doctor before no yeah
dude i had to yeah because you had
the surgery i thought it was highly
weird what is it called the dick doctor
urologist you're wrong
yeah oh i just googled dick doctor dick
doctor
yeah and it looked up andrologist is a
urologist andrologist that's like our ob
gyn
urologists treat patients of both
genders and for urinary problems as well
as male reproductive issues andrologists
are the male equivalent equivalent of
gynecologists focusing entirely on male
reproductive issues i was going to say
like yeah let's say you go to an and
drop and drop oh that's the student
who's also like study brains
penis no no no no no no no this is just
me oh okay imagine like one of us go and
we have like because girls got to do
their ob gyn thing right so i'm just
trying to like relate like all right i
got to go do my thing get my dick check
whatever whatever and what if this
guy or girl [ __ ] they check it they
go oh that was pretty sick and i'm like
oh damn dude because like if they see
thousands of dick and mine kind of like
goes oh that's kind of dope dude like i
think that would make me pretty like
feel pretty cool so like she's a guy or
a girl who's saying this right
that's kind of dope dude
she goes professionally speaking yeah
you got a great dick hey just you know
i've seen thousands of dick before
yours is dope though because i'm
imagining that doctor
they chose to be a dick doctor because
that's their passion is like i love that
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna make my
passion my dream and they're gonna
follow his dick dreams right mike so
then the doctors did the opposite when
he saw mike
yeah you really was well because yours
was mutilated right
dude you lost your dick right in third
grade you got it cut off right right
yeah it looked like one of the twisty
churros at the fair he doesn't know
about your day tell him about it no it's
it's because i i didn't get i didn't get
circumcised until it was like 12. so
then you're the great age to do it and
then they accidentally cut the whole
thing off
crazy dude you have to go see the
urologist and then the urologist like
it's it's a i remember having the same
exact question and i asked my dad i was
like what makes a guy wanna like look at
dick all the time
and then my dad basically broke it down
really simple was he like he's a gay
[Laughter]
you have to suck it
my dad's japanese
he my dad just said he just said you
just go where the money is that's it
he goes like he goes that's probably
right he goes they're gonna pay more for
something that less people are gonna do
and then since then ryan's been obsessed
with dicks
follow the money son i fashioned myself
as an amateur dick doctor myself
amateur andrologist but yeah he the the
dick doctor just like was crap like
handling myself wow
well because it's because it's it's so
clinical that he's not going to be
delicate he's just like okay let's see
here and he just started it's just like
so
and if you're uncircumcised you have
like so much skin all the way to the
thing the first thing you did just
pulled it back
like if you've never i've never done
that i didn't even know i got to do it
you're like that's like getting a male
cherry pop yeah i didn't even know i
could do that i just pulled the whole
thing back
yeah wait how did you do that when it's
not like erect you just like hold the
tip and literally yeah you [ __ ]
unroll it like a sock bro
exactly don't be looking at me like
you're angry dude that's making me feel
no my [ __ ] wasn't cut when i was [ __ ]
48.
i'm uncircumcised so i know
[Laughter]
you